hello and welcome during this session
we're going to present an in-depth demo
where we will build the necessary
infrastructure to support a fairly
sophisticated scenario for the vocal
burst case from customers on-prem
environment to google cloud
there is a lot to cover so let's get
started the idea behind this
demonstration is to showcase the cloud
benefits for eda customers that consider
to start their journey to cloud
specifically to highlight the features
such as cloud elasticity flexibility and
scalability
and the real value that cloud can bring
to these companies which is a shorter
time to market
the ability to access much larger
resource posts in the cloud enables
engineering teams to compress the total
time it takes to complete their jobs
and with eda workloads running in the
cloud these teams can perform more
design iterations per day and get these
designs out to the market much faster
we are going to start off by presenting
the setup we've used to create this demo
we've tried to build a simplified
architecture and have tried it to be as
close as possible to real-world the
architectures used today by some of our
customers
and to run a flow that resembles dda
burst-to-class scenario
this demo consists of seven steps and we
will go over each one before diving in
going to start with on-prem system
preparations from on-prem worker we will
install and configure the open piton
which is an open source general proposed
multi-threaded manicore processor
framework environment
in our case we're exploiting it as an
infrastructure that is used to configure
and run simulations and in particular
will serve as a source for configuration
files that will be used for regression
runs in gcp
next we are going to deploy two netapp
civil instances in gcp using terraform
and configure the flex cache
relationships between on-prem and gcp
environments
we will configure netapp cvo1 to act as
both high performance storage 3d
workloads in the cloud and as a cache
for open patent configuration files from
on-premises
to an ada workload in the cloud the
configuration files appear to be local
and there is no need to mirror all the
tools and libraries to the cloud get
just the data you need where and when
you need it
we will configure the netapp cvo2
instance as a target for the cloud
regression run results and by creating a
reverse cache relationship these results
appear to be local to engineers working
on on-prem
during this step we are going to create
islam cluster later on we will use
special arguments that are provided to
the regression run command and launch
each test in islam bad job allowing for
tests to be run in parallel
here we will run to regression runs
first we'll be using 10 gcp workers and
the second will use 20 gcp workers the
goal will be to present the effect of
compute scaling in the flex cache
technology implementation
next we are going to present one of the
benefits behind the flex cache we will
showcase the ability to access the same
files from both on-prem and gcp
environments by going over the
regression runs results from both
locations
going forward we will demonstrate a case
where this regression runs results can
be copied to google cloud storage for
later on analysis or archiving
and the last step will be just the gcp
environment cleanup we will delete it
all and remain just with the regression
run results in gcs
so let's dive into the demo
as it was presented before we're
starting with an on-prem environment
configuration
as you can see here we are using the
netapp hardware storage system
from the on-prem worker pre-monitored to
the on-prem volume we are installing
don't make pita environment
while created configuration files will
be used as a source for the future
regression runs in gcp
we switch over to the gcp environment
where we will deploy two netapp civil
instances using terraform followed by
the flex cache relationships
configuration
we're starting with the clear
environment
and through connection to the bastion
host we are verifying the correctness of
prepare header from configuration in
starting the deployment process
after executing the deployment the
progress can be monitored through netapp
cloud manager interface and once it
completes we got the relevant
information that will be used in the
next steps of the demo
by refreshing google cloud console
window we can see two new gc instances
are created
having completed the cvo's deployment we
are going right in and creating the flex
cache relationships
first we will create the connection
where the on-prem volume will serve as a
source and the cvo one will be
configured with the flex hash volume
to speed up the configuration process we
will use a simple pattern script that
utilizes the net upon top rest api
commands to preparing the figure deflect
cache relationship we insert the
required information about both source
and target netapp systems and execute
the script
once it's done we are continuing with
what is called cushion configuration
where the severe two volume will be used
as a source and the on-prem netapp
system will be configured with the flex
cache volume
we will use the same method of executing
the configuration through the prepared
head of the time script
we can verify the successful
configuration by accessing the on-prem
worker and trying to mount it to create
any minute ago on-prem flex cache volume
having enabled the flex question
relationships we are heading and
deploying the islam workload manager
this manager will be used to orchestrate
over the regression runs in gcp
the link to slam deployment files can be
found in the comments below or in the
demo walkthrough documentation
the slam will be deployed using
terraform so we switch over to the
configuration file and update it with
all the relevant information required
for the deployment
again
all the information can be found in the
demo walkthrough documentation
it takes a couple of minutes for the
installation to complete
we can see the new slarm instances are
created in our project and it will take
additional 15 minutes for the deployment
process to complete
while waiting for the slum deployment
completion we are going to create
performance dashboards using google
cloud monitoring
the goal is to be able to follow the io
flow during the regression rounds and
present the netapp cvo's read write
throughputs
we can verify slarm deployment
successful completion by connecting to
the slum login note it's mounted to both
netapp ceos we can access on-prem data
using flex cache and slam nodes are
ready to be allocated to run the
workload
now we are ready to execute the
regression runs first we will be using
10 workers and then we'll perform the
same but we're scaling the workers from
10 to 20. each regression run will
include 46 tests the run will be started
from the slara login node and once
started it will require the access to
relevant configuration files which are
currently located at on-prem data volume
once these files are cached local in gcp
slaran bad job is started allowing for
regression tests to be run in parallel
new regression run results directory is
created at civier2 and 10 new compute
instances are created in our project
and now let's monitor the ai flow
newly created workers are mounting to
both netapp cvo instances and reading
the run configuration data through cvo1
since the data is not presented locally
it is fetched from on-prem volume of
course all that is completely
transparent to the workers running to
test in gcp and the configuration files
appear for them to be local
we can see that the worker cpu
transition is getting higher once they
are starting to run the test
and the test results are written back to
dedicated volume created at netapp
sever2 instance
once we are done with the first
regression run we want to verify that
the results folder is accessible for
both gcp and on-prem environments
first we're accessing the results folder
located at cbr2 from gcp instance and as
you can see there is a list of the
completed tests now using the flex cache
we can access exactly the same folder
from on-prem worker and can read any of
the files from there
before continue to the next step we can
refresh the google cloud console window
and we can see that all the 10 workers
are deleted automatically by the storm
upon job
completion and now we will execute the
same regression run but this time with
20 instead of 10 workers
the first step will be to update the
islam configuration and validate it
we're changing the number of workers to
be deployed from 10 to 20
and validating the configuration saved
starting a new job right now the new run
starts quicker since the part of the
configuration files already cached and
located locally in the cloud
once new job is started we can see that
the new irrigation run results directory
is created at civio 2 and 20 new compute
instances are created at our project
while monitoring dia flow we can
identify pretty much the same behaviors
as we did with the first run but this
time
much less data is fetched from on-prem
environment since it's already partially
cached in the cloud
workers maximum read throughput is twice
higher than with previous run
and while writing back the results to
severe to instance the overall max
throughput is higher
all that happens because we have now
twice workers running the same workload
in parallel
this round completes much faster in
comparison to the first attempt and the
time savings are very clear
and again as with previous run we can
validate that all the results can be
accessible for the further analysis
from both environments
gcp and the on-prem
by refreshing our google cloud console
window we can verify that all the
workers are deleted again by the alarm
automatically upon the completion of the
test
now when we have all the results in the
gcp we can move it to a less expensive
storage option where it can be accessed
later on for further analysis or just
being archived
we are creating new gcs bucket and
copying both results directories there
once copied it can be accessed through
google cloud console or by any other
available means
having done all that and assuming that
we currently don't need anything else
from our cloud infrastructure we can go
ahead and clean it all
after deleting the flex cache
configuration we proceed to deleting the
netapp cdos using terraform
while running that we can destroy slarm
deployment as well again by using the
terraform
once everything is completed we can see
that our gcp project is empty in our
regression runs results are still
remaining for access to gcs
you